[Music]
some of my favorite looks at the oscars
last night were of course zendaya
who did a very you know an update on a
classic look that sharon stone did
actually in 1998 who's famous for doing
this hi-lo thing with a gap-white shirt
and a ball gown and cinderella just
modernized it youthfulized it and made
it really incredible zoey kravitz was
adorable very audrey hepburn
[Music]
nicole kidman was flawless as usual i
mean literally there was nothing to
criticize about that look jessica
chastain i think was incredible
it was very bold yet it was also subdued
i loved the way the top of her gown kind
of mirrored the color of her hair
they're not worse it's just things i
didn't necessarily like and billy eilish
was one of them i think she's adorable
i'm a huge fan of hers but i just
thought that wearing a very large gown
like that it just devoured her
one of the trends that i noticed was a
lot of younger women were wearing these
cut out dresses that were cut out on the
side much more revealing than one would
expect to be worn to the oscars a lot of
rule breakers last night kristen stewart
and timothy shellman so kristen's
wearing like you know just kind of i
mean literally a rock and roll oscars
look like you would never think someone
would wear that who's nominated you know
to the oscars at least you wore a shirt
because timothy did not and timothy's
look was vuitton women's wear which is
kind of cool i don't know if there's a
trend that's kind of you know this other
this younger generation just giving an
fu to the academy just saying you know
what solve nonsense none of this means
anything no one's the best actor you
know we get why we're here
we're just gonna dress the way we wanna
dress